[Music]
historically at least in recent times
baseball has always been
you know the last the last to the dance
we've seen
female coaches and other sports come
about
and now we're starting to see it in
baseball we had san francisco giants
we have a new gm first time ever
bianca smith a black woman in baseball
that's unheard of how do you feel i'll
start with you doc
it's different like you mentioned um
from my time that when you're in ryan's
place too
it wasn't gonna talk like decisions and
definitely what i thought in boston
i mean just being a black coach from
boston's period
what happened in my time um so things is
definitely happening
i think it's great it's good to see um
i just like to see if you're
disqualified give the chance
as far as women like women um former
players black players whatever
it's front office managers coaches i
mean there's so many
great like players for games you're not
great tips to kill the talent you're
great because of your knowledge as well
the level of inclusiveness um i think is
is amazing now i mean like you said um
having a female gm female coaches
i mean kudos man i i'm very excited for
that because i'm from
i'm a firm believer of like who it's all
about who is the best person
for the job if you got somebody who can
come in and do the job
why not hire them whether they're male
whether they're female whether they're
black whether they're white or they're
asian
give them the opportunity because either
they're gonna come in they're gonna get
the job done or they're not
so i think to be able to be that
inclusive
and start having uh female coaches
female
gms and front office workers in
operations
in baseball operations not just working
in the front office but
having a say so in personnel
and what have you on the team man i'm
all i'm all for it
i don't really think that it matters if
you're a male or female
as long as they are qualified our minor
league hitting
coordinator there's a woman we just
hired her and she's been in our
organization for the past
four years and i mean she's well
respected in the clubhouse by everybody
as players we just want to be you know
told things that's going to help us
succeed and be put in position to
succeed and you know whoever can do that
job
we're going to give them a fair shake
treat a woman no different than you
would treat a man
same as you're doing you know regular
life and you know i'm excited to see how
that goes
you know i think you know they hired
those women for a reason we could talk
about
you know what it's like being black only
getting one
shot having to be twice as good
as our counterparts to even get seen
you imagine what it's like for a woman
she has to be
ten times as good just to be heard first
of all and to be
taken seriously it goes to show that
these women
fought the fight they had a reason to go
forward we had a reason to fight
they had more of a reason to fight and
it's just lovely seed like i said
although we're last of the dance in mlb
that is happening
and hopefully it continues to go and
that they're setting a precedent
for young women that want an opportunity
in sports